let's go to our next caller why don't we
try the six for six
area code six for six is always
interesting because it could be
Manhattan but it also could be just
people who are from New York and live
elsewhere six for six tell us who you
are where you're calling from and what's
on your mind today oh great and speak up
as much as you can let's turn Johnny up
as much as we can so I can hear him okay
hey David I'm Johnny yeah I'm from New
York and there were reports that our
Debra buys there was bias in the Russian
investigation and the Hillen
investigation I'm sorry Hillary
investigation because of some text that
an agent sent that were anti Trump and
Pro Hillary I don't think it's a big
deal
since that agent was removed this past
summer and it's not like he had absolute
influence on those investigations anyway
and I was wondering if you think that
it's a serious problem no I don't I mean
that that was handled in the way I would
have expected it to be handled the the
right seems to be I forget even the
agents name who was caught sending some
kind of anti Trump text message and
caught like the dork or to work with
something yeah something like that
it was handled correctly the right is
framing it as though that individual had
just an inordinate amount of influence
over the entire investigation there's no
actual evidence to suggest that they did
there's a chain of command
everything happened exactly the way it
was supposed to and by the way uh
everybody involved in all of these
investigations has personal opinions
just because not everybody sends a text
and we find out about it doesn't mean
that the investigations aren't filled
with people who are partisan the
question is are they acting in a
partisan way in their role within the
investigation yeah I'm wondering have
you seen some of the Texas it's been a
little while since I looked at them but
yeah I mean clearly the guy was like an
anti-trump guy and one more question
yeah with how polarizing the 2016
election was do you think it's even
possible to investigate Trump without
bias
I am naively thinking that Robert Muller
is going to get to the sort of bottom of
it and we will eventually really know
the full scope of what happened but I I
may be naive in that and you might be
a question might be implying something
that's true which is but maybe that's
not going to be possible
I hope though that we are able to get to
the bottom of it okay that's all the
quicker that happen all right thanks so
much appreciate the call always great to
hear from people from the old home of
the David Pakman show new york city